well the resurgence of black lives
matter rioting continued last night
spreading from philadelphia into new
york dc
new york was the second city in as many
nights to see cops run down
by rampaging motorists in philadelphia
uh chaos reigned across several city
blocks as dozens of stores were
ransacked everything from shoes to
large appliances were hauled away by
thieves looters even hit
chick-fil-a cartigoff i guess fistfuls
of ketchup packets and
chick-fil-a sauce and plastic forks and
this in spite of the fact that dan cathy
the ceo of chick-fil-a recently got
got on his knees in front of an audience
and shined a black man's shoes publicly
in order to demonstrate his racial
enlightenment
yet they still looted his story just
goes to show once again that
you might as well retain your dignity
because it will profit you nothing to
forfeit
forfeit it anyway it's not it's not
going to accomplish what
you hope it accomplishes more tragically
some of the stores
had only recently in philadelphia that
have been looted had only recently
reopened after being decimated during
the first round of rioting
back in may and now these business
owners must rebuild all over again
or else finally give up trying to do
business in communities
that will leap at the first opportunity
to pillage their shelves and take
food out of their children's mouths in
fact let's play a quick uh
montage of some of the action last night
if you missed it just for your reference
here it is
[Applause]
that's what i like
so there it is and and such is life
under a democrat mayor and governor
indeed pennsylvania governor tom wolf
has been
relentless in pursuing and punishing
dangerous degenerates who commit the
crime of
walking down the street without a mask
but is expectedly
less determined to do anything at all
about the looters currently terrorizing
his most populous city
speaking to reporters woof a man with
the distinct aura of a
henpecked substitute science teacher who
can't control his class
had this to say as everyone is
really sad by the the
death of of the victim and and i think
i uh share in mourning with the family
anytime that happens is a tragedy for
whatever reason
uh and i think we need to make sure that
that we follow up
find out what happened i'm and my staff
and
have been in constant communication
since last night
with the folks in philadelphia and the
hope is that that
doesn't escalate into anything uh more
than the peaceful protests that
that i think this kind of situation
brings out
and the hope is that this doesn't
escalate into anything more than
peaceful protests
that this kind of situation brings out
it doesn't escalate into anything more
than peaceful protest
he made this statement of course
implying stating that it's peaceful
protest
he made the statement after rioters had
already spent the previous night looting
and burning
and at least one police officer had been
sent to the hospital with broken bones
this apparently qualifies as peaceful
protests it's not clear
what would need to happen in order to be
considered an escalation in tom wolf's
mind
whatever it is my guess is that the
rioters would have to change their
political affiliation
and in many cases probably their skin
color to earn a real rebuke
from the governor of the once proud
commonwealth of pennsylvania
this is what democrats do though when
you elect them to run your city or state
they simply sit back and they let it all
burn
chiming in occasionally to offer words
of encouragement to the people holding
the matches
we've seen this same plot unfold over
and over and over again
from from philly to new york to
minneapolis to kenosha to seattle and so
on
democrat leaders will not enforce the
law
in portland the police have been so
thoroughly gelded
that they're now reduced to tweeting
desperate pleas to rioters
the same riders who've held their city
hostage for half a year
now they have to tweet at them to get
them to stop on wednesday night the
portland pd twitter account
sent out this message very pitiful it
reads
uh to those marching on north denver
avenue please be mindful of those who
live in this community do not engage in
criminal behavior to include obstructing
vehicular traffic and vandalizing
private property
we ask you to encourage those who are
engaged in criminal criminal behavior to
stop
shockingly this does not appear to have
deterred a single lawbreaker
uh perhaps the police department will
have to pull out the big guns and start
tweeting angry gifts
at the anarchist next i don't know now
we could joke about this of course but
the consequences of democrat governance
are not funny
they are predictable and if you vote to
elect these people to lead you
everything that happens next all of the
chaos and destruction
that you had to know would come is your
fault partly
and you deserve it you quite literally
asked for it
these are the the fruits of the trees
you planted
the only problem is that many others in
your city or state
who did not vote the same way um but
found themselves outnumbered by these
self-destructive
incredulous people like you must also
reap what you have sown now
one other thing related to the
philadelphia situation that i wanted to
mention
more information has come to light about
walter wallace jr who's the man who
approached
philly police while brandishing a knife
um
and whose seemingly justified death at
their hands has ostensibly
sparked the latest round of writing now
as uh as local abc affiliate in
in the city reports wallace was an
aspiring rapper
who's quote central themes in his music
were guns and shooting people we're also
told that he rapped about social justice
it's uh it seems mysterious how someone
can be fascinated with shooting people
while being simultaneously concerned
with social justice but this is a
this is a needle that most rappers try
unsuccessfully to thread
now wallace has a lengthy rap sheet uh
he had a prior arrest for assaulting a
police officer
it's not clear whether the the officer
is responding to the 911 call
shortly before his death knew about that
incident or not but more
noteworthy is his 2017 conviction for
robbery and assault reportedly
that crime involved kicking down the
door of another woman and putting a gun
to her head
now if this sounds familiar that's
because george floyd was convicted of
doing
almost exactly the same thing except in
his case he forced his way into a
woman's home
and put a gun to her stomach rather than
her head so wallace's actions
are reminiscent of things we've already
seen including jacob blake who allegedly
broke into a woman's house raped her
then stole her debit card in her vehicle
if you're keeping track at home
that makes three recent blm martyrs with
a history
in two cases confirmed in one case very
credibly alleged
of brutalizing and abusing women in
unspeakable ways
we could also add to the list ricardo
munoz uh who's the man
shot by lancaster police after charging
at them with a knife he had several
previous
convictions the worst one being a recent
spree where he stabbed four people
including a minor and a 22 year old
woman though he did appear to be an
equal opportunity felon
uh in fairness stabbing men and women
alike
now all of these men have been
performatively
mourned the names of at least two of
them and now probably three when walter
wallace has added to it have graced the
helmets of
nfl players they've been memorialized
as heroes of their community joe biden
infamously visited
with the credibly accused rapist jacob
blake's family
and spoke with blake himself on the
phone um
and complimented him afterwards last
night biden tweeted out his heartbreak
over the death of wallace
and while we're implored to say the
names of these men
and celebrate their lives and weep over
their deaths or injuries in blake's case
their female victims are erased from the
discussion
their names are not mentioned or allowed
to be mentioned
their suffering does not count nobody
ever stops to ask
how they must feel to see their abusers
lauded in this way
nobody asks for their perspective and if
they were to offer it they'd be shouted
down
or worse and we all know that this is
what blm and the democrat party thinks
of women who
don't fit neatly into the script don't
cooperate with the program
mostly they think nothing of them they
don't acknowledge their existence
and we're expected to follow that lead
making the violent criminals into
victims but never speaking a word about
the victims of the violent criminals
it is by this silence that the left
crafts and maintains its narrative
so i say we should not be silent
about it anymore hey you uh yeah
you you're right you right there hit the
subscribe button right now
do it do it right now i thank you for
your compliance
it's somewhat appreciated